gehört etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video hatte
ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut ich hoffe
wir können ein bisschen näher an die
kamera also noch platz ist also jetzt
bei einem ja das sagen aber dass
grammatikalisch nicht korrekt nicht
affolter ein gast bei mir einmal für
dynamische derzeit li na h hinter der
kamera doch mal lädt die macht hat die
kamera
danke hast du films super vielleicht
darf man nicht auch mal im video sehen
danke und zwar starten wir heute
rhein-main praktisch ersten part von 9
format untersagt so ergreift ich habe
mir das überlegt ich wollte nämlich auch
wieder mehr essens kundig machen er
störte mich auch sehr viel gemacht für
die schreiber auch alex wann kommt mal
wieder was mit essen wohl deswegen
machen wir heute was ich denke ihr euch
ganz kurz das format es ist ja so dass
man als in florenz hat trotzdem auf
aktuell noch die möglichkeit hat man
irgendwo hinzufahren sei es jetzt soll
man dort irgendwas dreht muss oder auch
einfach weil man dann selbstständig ist
und vielleicht dort sagen wir mal noch
mal hat dort irgendwo im termin sowie
gehe zwar davon aus demnächst auf jeden
fall noch auf den köln/düsseldorf
vielleicht auch mal in hamburg und
berlin oder münchen so und deswegen
dachte ich mir
wir machen es so dass bedroht immer die
besten essen testen von die verwandlung
das habe ich damals schon auf die macht
als in köln gewundert habe ich so ich
teste das beste von planer bleiben und
das ist die idee von 9 format wir
schlagen heute hier in meiner vortag
ja die gibt es auch einige restaurants
und celina und marie sind heute bei und
dürfen mit listen wir suchen uns jetzt
was leckeres aus und probieren ja ihr
habt ja verstanden worum es geht wir
gehen jetzt einfach mal an sich auf
lieferando ich bin jetzt übrigens auch
dabei halten genau stellt das so vor ich
bin dann im nächsten mal in einer
anderen stadt und sucht dann das beste
restaurant aus natürlich gibt es
verschiedene wahrscheinlich die fünf von
fünf sterne haben
deswegen nehme ich dann immer die die
fünf von fünf stellen haben und die
meisten bewertungen
das ist ja hier haben wir jetzt einmal
dass hier das ristorante pizzeria de
poli
ich muss sagen es ist lang italienisch
bin ich schon fast ein bisschen
langweilig
man muss halt auch vielleicht mal sein
324 bewertung dann ristorante pizzeria
roma auch sehr lecker glaube ich habe
ich noch nie probiert so dann haben wir
noch die pizzeria 50 euro muss von
hubble stellen
aber die haben wir auch den dollar 702 5
sterne bewertung sozusagen freut sich
beteiligen ist weil es das jetzt so was
von troja dann ist mir schon ziemlich zu
bestellen ist habe ich nichts zu tun das
geht ich würde sagen ihr dürft anfang
isotow heraus was sie haben wollte und
dann kommen die bioproduktion okay man
muss leider aussagen hier auf dem dorf
gibt es nicht so viel also in hamburg
oder köln ich da schon deutlich größere
ausgaben im nächsten bei mir daheim
machen
ja wobei bei dir gibst habe ich gar
nicht so alt ist oder auf die tat doch
ja
wollt ihr denn wollte besser also jeder
darf das bestellen was er will egal wie
teuer das ist ganz wichtig und wir
müssen auch ein breitgefächertes
sortiment haben gibt es ein trüffel
nudeln solche wir sehen uns gleich
wieder wir machen schnelldurchlauf
bestellen dass man zeigen wir euch was
sie bestellt haben bis gleich war hier
gibt's einfach pizza hot dog wie
christian wenigen gurken denn im monat
obwohl vielleicht ist das gar nicht so
schlecht für 200 noch nie gehört
es ist eine pizza hot frauen ja aber
wahrscheinlich nur liegt also nur wurst
habe trug
wobei früher habe ich auch gerne so wenn
man so bitzer selber belegen dürfte so
diese mini würstchen auf blick.ch
ja aber man musste sich angucken dann
bist du nicht die x wir haben jetzt
folgen das bestellen also insgesamt 452
euro 10 schon ein bisschen fühlen oder
sonst schafft man das alles sonst
morgens zu früh standen ok einmal polo
dazu bestellt dann haben wir pasta al
arabija plus von logik chicken wings
country potatoes natürlich man muss
sagen dass er bevor jetzt sollte
kritisieren das ist eher ein italiener
man sollte ja dort auch dann eigentlich
nur italienische sachen bestellen aber
ich finde so ausgefallene sachen bieten
die auf wann habe ich zum beispiel noch
nie gehörten und teller taschen oder
auch hier unten hatten wir pro komitees
gab jetzt kann man ja dann auch mal
probieren wenn die firmen stellen genau
dann haben wir doch mal von schoko
country potatoes da oben machen
blueberry pizza doch da freue ich mich
schon sehr drauf pizza rucola wohl
politik es hat mir schon und ja das war
es ein bisschen was du kriegen 52
bestellen und ja 2000 jahre später ich
habe noch nie in meinem leben so lange
aufs essen auf jeden fall will dann
haben wir gewartet 200 stunden ohne
scheiß auf jeden fall über zwei stunden
und 40 minuten die cola darf sogar
umsonst gratis dazu
jetzt macht mir mut gelobt werden
auch die witze lotto leute das ist pizza
hot bird sings
dann haben wir hier noch irgendwelche
die crackers chili cheese im käse
gefragt das war theresa profil hoch das
sind wie so eine trainer wenger oder
kalter und dann haben wir hier noch die
soße letzte könnt euch mal zuerst nur
wie die heimat kurs also hier auf
twitter ist auf jeden fall ziemlich
fließe dann so schön aus wenn das lecker
ist warum nicht und hier das ist sehr
künftig aber auch er kann darf mit dem
server
das ist die form ist und die sind
natürlich mache ich immer noch war und
auch noch bringt so mäßig wir sind nicht
so leicht ob man diese haut pizza und
müssen wir nicht gleich anprobieren
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen meine
bachelor feiere ich nicht zu hoch
schwierig also direkt an die es so
irgendwie weiß nicht das passt nicht
zusammen
das schmeckt wie ein schlechter salat
auf apples meister sondern schlechter
dort denkt dann stimme ein paar fragen
wir beantworten jetzt muss man das
machen beim advent keine ahnung wie
machen wir jetzt einfach aber an sich
bei mir im video geht ja ums essen und
nicht umgehen welche fragen ich war
jetzt mal hier an die hot pizza wann
riecht schon nach otto
ich war nicht meins
gut also dass schlechte idee mit der
ocha
also ich muss sagen so richtig kastoria
ist irgendwie nicht so mein fall
ja das ist gut das ist bis jetzt das
beste von allen
und die sind auch in ordnung diese
trackers ich finde die pisten sind sehr
schön aus der kritik aber das macht mir
das nicht wirklich jetzt nicht sooo geil
aber trotzdem interessant dass die 5 und
5 sterne haben man muss dazu sagen heute
ist der erste mai feiertag und die
hatten wohl sehr viel zu tun deswegen
auf die kasse verspätung nur wenn ich
bei fünf von fünf sternen gestaltet
denke ich mir auch so das wird auf jeden
fall echt krass lecker meint verbrennt
irgendwie überfordert mich das wenn man
so viele sachen bestehen hat aber ich
hatte den ganzen tag
diese nudeln richtig lecker aber der
rest ist so bis jetzt so sehr dass er
leute willkommen zum absoluten finale
weswegen dieses restaurant auf 5 5
sterne hat und zwar der nachtisch der
nah waren wir noch zwei muffins oder so
die leute das geld ganz kurz und zwar
muss ich mich einmal entschuldigen bei
marie weil es echt manchmal so wirkt als
würde ich überhaupt nicht auf sie
eingehen das liegt auch daran ich habe
dieses video nicht selber gestimmten
also manchmal ist es halt keine ahnung
daher habe ich bestimmt was gesagt aber
es wird halt rausgeschnitten also es war
überhaupt nicht meine absicht klar
gesagt ein bisschen gestaffelt und die
kamera stand davon daher habe ich eher
einmal dass elina geguckt bevor ich
jetzt von euch ärger bekommen wollte ich
mich dafür einmal entschuldigen und beim
nächsten mal achte ich darauf dass es
nicht so passiert ich würde sagen wir
starten erst mal mit nutella taschen für
54 die kann man so auch zu leisten
aufbrechen und sieht dann wie die
nutella hier auch so live von allen
leuten nicht aus trotzdem probieren
warum
[Musik]
in blätterteig und das bisschen hart ein
also nicht habe aber so ein bisschen ist
das ein bisschen pizzateig matratzen
kommt bestimmt
darum geht es ja auch und die
kreativität das habe ich noch nirgendwo
anders gesehen weil man bei einer
pizzeria nutella tranche dass man die
bei lieferanten bestellen kann das war
mir neu leute jetzt schauen wir mal hier
in den muffin rein und raus springt
gehört ich dachte wenn gefühlen und
einer mit 150 gleich mit ein bisschen
wieder geschmack das merkt man doch
nicht machen noch mehr besucher masters
die tiere aus ihren häusern
das werden wir morgen anfang auch nicht
wirklich nicht aus sollte man die ganzen
titel ich kann heute also ich muss sagen
wir müssen berücksichtigen wir sind hier
auf dem land hier gibt es nicht so viel
deswegen wenn das nächste video aus köln
düsseldorf hamburg brauchen man kommt
das wird richtig heißes essen werden
also so krasses essen wirklich glaube
ich das war jetzt hier so ein bisschen
auch 0 abruft sind bis auf den teller
tassen und die bonität des neckars für
mich wäre das jetzt her keine 5 und 5
sterne trotzdem in ordnung also mit
michael becker hohem niveau wir sind
sagt das ist das wichtigste
genau solche sagen fürs zuschauen ihr
könnt ihr mal super gerne weitere städte
wo ich das machen soll in die kommentare
schreiben
vielleicht mache ich dann einfach das
was die meisten likes hat jack auf
serena das video auf dem video gedreht
jaha sehr gut war dass und navi und
selina auch auf uns haben hier verlinkt
leute haut rein